organe können jetzt deutlich länger
konserviert werden um dann menschen
eingepflanzt werden also transplantiert
zu werden bei organtransplantationen
zählt jede sekunde eine große
herausforderung bei dieser
lebensrettenden maßnahme ist es die
organe und gewebe teile außerhalb des
körpers für eine längere zeit zu lagern
damit sie im falle einer transplantation
sofort einsatzbereit sind
bisher lag die grenze so bei etwa neun
stunden einem us forschungsteam ist nun
ein entscheidender durchbruch gelungen
die forscher haben eine neue technik
entwickelt mit denen menschliche
spenderorgane bei minustemperaturen
konserviert werden können durch super
cooling überlebten die organe deutlich
länger und zwar ohne schaden zu nehmen
klicks um science-fiction gibt es
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktivierte glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen bei transplantationen müssen
die spender organe wie nieren und leber
zum beispiel innerhalb von neun stunden
beim empfänger sein ansonsten werden
zellen und strukturen beschädigt und
eine transplantation ist nicht mehr
möglich
das ist eine zusätzliche herausforderung
für die ärzte teams ganz zu schweigen
davon dass spenderorgane ja sowieso sehr
knapp sind doch die naheliegende idee
organe einfach einzufrieren und dann bei
bedarf wieder aufzutauen
die ist leider nicht möglich denn die
bildung von eiskristallen führt zu
irreparablen schäden
bislang werden die organe also in einer
kühlbox über null grad transportiert und
jede sekunde zählt eine neue methode
namens super cooling könnte hierbei eine
enorme erleichterung bedeuten einem us
forschungsteam ist es jetzt gelungen
menschliche leber transplantate unter
den gefrierpunkt zu kühlen und am ende
wieder zu erwärmen ohne dass die organe
schaden genommen haben das super cooling
ermöglichte es sogar dass die lebern
erheblich länger außerhalb eines
menschlichen körpers überlebten
abgeschaut hat sich die fachwelt diese
neu entwickelte technik aus der natur
denn auch manche tiere können durch
solch einen trick den winter gut
überstehen konkret wurden die
menschlichen leben auf minus vier grad
heruntergekühlt der clou durch die
zugabe von speziellen frostschutzmitteln
wird verhindert dass sich eiskristalle
bilden die das gewebe schädigen könnten
die sorgt vereinfacht gesagt dafür dass
die temperaturen des wassergehalts in
den
organ auf minusgrade abgesenkt werden
ohne dass ein gefrier prozess
stattfindet schon vor einigen jahren war
es dem us forschungsteam gelungen lebern
von ratten auf minus sechs grad
herunterzukühlen und zwar ohne dass die
organe der tiere dabei ein von doch wie
so oft ist solch ein tierversuch eben
nicht eins zu eins auf uns menschen
übertragbar
schließlich sind unsere organe bis zu
200 mal größer dazu der
us-wissenschaftler trainieren de vries
die größer das volumen desto schwieriger
wird es die bildung von eiskristallen
bei minustemperaturen zu verhindern
trotz dieser enormen herausforderung ist
es den fachleuten um de vries gelungen
dieses verfahren jetzt auch bei
menschlichen leben anzuwenden
eine absolut echte premiere natürlich
wurde das verfahren etwas angepasst
unter anderem wurden weitere
frostschutzmittel hinzugegeben
beispielsweise glyzerin und reha lose
die die eisbildung verhindern und die
zellen stabilisieren die organe wurden
also nach und nach sehr gleichmäßig mit
diesen konservierungs flüssigkeiten
vollgepumpt die menschlichen leber
wandern eine perfusion maschine
angeschlossen und wurden so mit
nährstoffen und sauerstoff versorgt
durch die minustemperaturen
verlangsamten sich physiologische
prozesse extrem die organe wurden quasi
in eine art scheintot versetzt eine
wichtige erkenntnis der fachleute der
kontakt mit luft muss unbedingt
verhindert werden denn dadurch würde das
risiko für eine kristallbildung auf der
oberfläche der organe erhöht um die
menschlichen leben wieder aufzuwecken
wurde ihnen warmes blut zugeführt und
die organe langsam wieder auf
raumtemperatur gebracht und das ergebnis
ist tatsächlich erfolgsversprechend denn
die lebern hatten alles gut überstanden
durch den einsatz des super bowls
überlebten sie bis zu 27 stunden
außerhalb des körpers und war danach
genauso funktionsfähig wie zuvor eben
einen anderen körper verbrannt wurden
die leber noch nicht doch simulationen
legen nahe dass dies womöglich klappen
würde ganz klar also dass verfahren weg
tatsächlich neue hoffnung in sachen
organtransplantation
denn durch die methode könnte wertvolle
zeit gewonnen werden die lebern könnten
zum beispiel um die halbe erdkugel
geflogen werden was bisher einfach nicht
möglich war
dazu die wissenschaftlerin fantasy die
an dem versuch beteiligt war
wenn ein organ verfügbar ist ist ein
geeigneter empfängern
nicht immer in der nähe eine längere
haltbarkeit bedeutet mehr zeit für die
suche nach einem passenden patienten und
den transport und das bedeutet dass
weniger spender organ entsorgt werden
müssen und mehr patienten gut geeignete
organe erhalten mit denen sie lange
leben können auf diesem chip wachsen
organe anklicken anschauen und doktor
watson abonnieren super kanal bis dann
bleibt dran